[Music]
on this sunday night
killed while walking home
[Applause]
the global outcry after a british woman
is murdered
and a police officer is charged with her
death
ontario launches its vaccination booking
system why wasn't the
weren't these bookings done a few weeks
ago will it crash
like other provincial rollouts the
frontline workers
left behind we want to protect the rest
of the province
we protect our essential workers the
calls to vaccinate employees at big
businesses
and saying goodbye how the pandemic has
made losing a loved one
even more painful
national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in the united
kingdom where pressure is mounting on
london's police commissioner to resign
her officers are being criticized for
the way they treated people attending a
vigil
for sarah everard the
thirty-three-year-old was kidnapped and
killed earlier this month
the man accused of the crime as a
metropolitan police officer
she was just walking home and those
words have become a battle cry for many
women
who are sharing their own stories as
ross lord explains
everard's death has sparked anger across
the uk
and here in canada at a time of growing
questions about policing in the western
world
this is a public relations disaster
protesters in london
outraged not only that a police officer
allegedly killed sarah everard as she
was walking home at night
but also at police aggression against
people mourning her death
police removed women from the vigil
honoring everard leading some away in
handcuffs
while being accused of betrayal
[Applause]
online hashtags like she was just
walking home are resonating around the
world
with women who felt fear all of their
lives about
walking alone at night the simple
universal act of walking somewhere and
home especially
to go hopefully to a safe environment
and that you can be murdered simply
because you're female
for no other reason danielle jack from
bc's mamalikala first nation
led a march this weekend honoring
missing and murdered indigenous women
she's had her own horrific experiences
when i was 12 i was
abducted brutally raped and beaten
and stripped naked and left
in a ditch in the uk advocates note the
number of women murdered by men
is at an all-time high compounding the
despair
is the fact everard's alleged killer is
metropolitan police constable wayne
cousins
whose main job was patrolling diplomatic
buildings
the way police handled the vigil is
being criticized
some calling it an unthinkable insult i
think that the police got it wrong
at every single turn police said they
were simply enforcing
covet rules and were placed in this
position because of the overriding need
to protect people's safety
quite rightly as far as i can see my
team felt
this is now an unlawful gathering which
poses a considerable risk
to people's health according to the
regulations
a really invidious position for my
officers to find themselves in
but london's mayor said he khan says
police assured him
the vigil would be managed sensitively
after meeting with police leaders
khan said i am not satisfied with the
explanation they have provided
khan is calling for a full independent
investigation
the uk's home secretary is asking the
force for a full report on what happened
ross lord global news
outrage is growing over a cartoon
published by french satirical magazine
charlie hebdo it's a depiction of the
queen kneeling on the neck of the
duchess of sussex
echoing the killing of george floyd and
a warning the image may be offensive
the cartoon published yesterday is
titled why megan quit buckingham
megan is then drawn to say because i
couldn't breathe anymore
the cover image comes days after megan
and her husband prince harry made
allegations of racism within the royal
family
in an interview with oprah winfrey the
ceo of the uk's race equality think tank
tweeted the cartoon is wrong on every
level
this doesn't push boundaries make anyone
laugh or challenge racism
it demeans the issues and causes offense
across the board
now to the vaccination campaign
thousands of people in ontario will soon
be able to roll up their sleeves
the province is launching its booking
system for covet 19 vaccines tomorrow
with the capacity to book at least 800
000 appointments
but as morgan campbell reports there are
worries the demand will be too high for
the system to handle
as ontario expands its list of who can
get
and give a covet 19 shots a new tool
has been added to the vaccine rollout
we are ready we have the infrastructure
we have the the people the province is
launching
online and call center booking systems
which will allow
seniors over the age of 80 to book covid
19 vaccinations
that portal is live monday morning and
will only accept those born
in 1941 or earlier
retired general rick hillier who heads
up the province's vaccine program
says the system has been stress tested
to handle a high volume since friday
we booked more than 15 000 appointments
for toronto public health using the
online booking system
it was done without a flaw the same
can't be said for other provinces such
as
alberta and british columbia both
experienced
system-wide crashes due to the number of
people
trying to book online and over the phone
randy connolly
is a professor of mathematics and
computing at mount royal university
in calgary as long as they're
planning for that kind of load
they should be able to manage it it
doesn't mean
it's there's not going to be delays dr
kerry bowman says he
is concerned some people trying to book
appointments
may fall through the cracks because of
barriers ingrained
in the system i purposely repeat not
everyone has access to an advocate so
that will be a big one language you know
and then and then people that
you know simply don't even have phones
the province says it hopes to
open the online portal to those 75 and
older by
at least the beginning of april
meanwhile the ford government
has stressed that it does need the
federal government to provide
additional vaccines to ontario morgan
campbell global news toronto
frontline workers are hoping the
vaccination campaign will move
them up outbreaks at busy factories and
warehouses have been a common occurrence
during the pandemic
as catherine ward reports there are
calls to protect those employees
with the goal of protecting the rest of
the province
for every package food delivery and
purchase made
frontline workers in warehouses trucks
and factories
are the driving force keeping these
industries on track
this is certainly a place where you know
prioritizing vaccination
would have a huge role to play in
changing the trajectory and really
bringing down the
spread of the disease infectious
diseases physician dr suman chakrabarti
says
vaccinating frontline workers in ontario
could be a game changer especially in
the region's hardest hit it's important
for us to
you know really put resources in to
protect them because this is one
unfortunate area that's invisible
but has been impacted very hard by covid
much more than the rest of the
population amazon was ordered by public
health officials to shut down a facility
in brampton on friday
after 240 positive cases were reported
in recent weeks at least 10 of those
involved
variants roughly 5 000 workers have been
instructed to quarantine
and self-isolate until march 27th mayor
patrick brown says
this is an example of how vaccines could
break
the cycle of transmission that has been
happening in his city
we've had outbreaks disproportionately
amongst our essential workers in peel
region and in toronto
and if we want to protect the rest of
the province we protect our essential
workers
when asked if the province would
prioritize the group retired general
rick hillier said
the rollout remains unchanged so the
plan for them is that they will be
included in either mass vaccination
clinics
or else in pharmacy channels as they
roll through or
in some of the public health units
however hillier did suggest
there could be opportunities for big
businesses to help with vaccine
distribution
at some point in the future perhaps many
private companies volunteering to set up
a mass vaccination clinic in their own
factories
using their own occupational health
personnel to do the vaccine and look
after their workers
when their turn comes as for amazon the
company has made it clear
it plans to appeal the shutdown order
given it does not believe the data
supports
a full closure the region's medical
officer of health says vaccines for
front-line workers will still largely
depend on supply
certainly another logical group for
consideration once we've
ticked off the tears of those who are
really at the at the highest risk of
mortal and severe outcomes at this time
catherine ward global news toronto
ontario is reporting more than
1700 cases of covet 19 today and
tomorrow
the province is easing restrictions for
religious services weddings and funerals
the capacity limits will change for
regions in the province's
great lockdown zones indoor gatherings
of up to 15 percent total capacity
will be permitted 50 people will be
allowed to gather outdoors
indoor public events and social
gatherings are still banned
alberta's first urban indigenous
vaccination clinic opens tomorrow
the clinic is located in calgary's
aboriginal friendship center
many indigenous people in the city
already turn to it for other health and
community needs
this will provide a culturally
appropriate space for indigenous seniors
living in the calgary area to get
vaccinated
without having to travel to reserves
ireland has become the latest country to
temporarily suspend the astrazeneca
covid19 vaccine
health officials in that country say
it's being made out of an abundance of
caution
denmark iceland and norway suspended the
vaccine
after reports of serious blood clots
norway's medicines
agency has detected four cases of blood
clots in adults
after receiving the astrazeneca vaccine
on friday the world health organization
said there's no indication
that they were caused by the vaccine
turning now to the wii charity
controversy
the organization's founders brothers
craig and mark kielberger
are set to appear before the house of
commons ethics committee
as david aiken reports opposition mps
say they still don't have a complete
picture of the ties between we
and the prime minister's family
virtually
very limited engagement with the federal
government seeking funds
the wii charity controversy is almost as
old as the pandemic itself
last spring when the trudeau government
wanted to hand out 900 million dollars
worth of grants to help students
it turned to we an organization which
had long been a favorite of prime
minister justin trudeau and members of
his family
who would often appear at the rock
concert events
staged by charity founders craig and
mark kielberger
but then it emerged that the trudeau
government had tapped the we charity
without a competitive tendering process
that we
then in financial trouble itself would
be paid millions to run the program
and that trudeau's wife mother and
brother had all been paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars by we
over the years
to appear at we events the trudeau
government dropped we from running the
student grant program but
the opposition has been howling about
liberal self-dealing and corruption
ever since the deep connections that the
kielburgers had
to justin trudeau to his family and how
they were able to walk in
basically you know they had the
all-access
pass and government shouldn't be
operating that way
what we see here is an example of the
poor judgment that the prime minister
has exercised
at first the kielburgers rejected the
summons by the commons ethics committee
but after an extraordinary exchange of
demands and counter demands
the brothers accompanied by their lawyer
agreed to testify
we have a duty to scrutinize you know
the concerning allegations about
uh the we organization misleading donors
and volunteers and students in
charitable groups this
goes back to that piece about the
vetting and did the prime minister did
members of his cabinet did
did pco know about these allegations
this is a charity
we've had to issue four legal summons in
order to get the key
leaders in this charity that works in
all our schools to testify
i want to know what is with that david
aiken global news
ottawa coming up winter isn't done just
yet delivering a crippling storm to the
u.s
and boxing legend marvelous marvin dies
suddenly
just when we thought it was getting
warmer mother nature had something else
in mind
a massive and very late winter wallop is
hitting the u.s tonight
southern california has been blanketed
in snow while texas is being hit with
tornadoes
tonight jennifer johnson looks at all
the chaos in what many hope will be
winter's
last wild ride oh man
it has been a rocky weekend for the
rocky mountain states
not good some of the heaviest snow in
years continues to fall
blizzard conditions in wyoming in utah
people were trapped in their cars for
hours
after massive multi-vehicle accidents
thousands of flights have been canceled
or delayed at denver's airport
had a couple flights canceled the
slow-moving storm caused colorado's
governor to activate the national guard
while urging people to stay put you
don't want to have to be one of those
that searched for and rescued
better to be safe at home in colorado's
back country officials posted several
avalanche warnings
after an already deadly season where at
least 11 people died
it's once in a lifetime a little ski
trip and
we're going to make the best best of it
even though the uh
you know you can't control mother nature
even normally sunny southern california
has been hit by the storm
mudslides and snow in san diego county
this family enjoyed the white stuff
seeing it for the first time look i
caught lots of snowflakes
feels great you know after work of a
week of
working at home the snow also amazed
visitors in southern nevada
this was a surprise this was not yeah it
was not our place
but yeah we love it what a treat
and they're liking it it's the first
time they've had snow
in texas several tornadoes ripped across
the panhandle
knocking out power and destroying homes
we got alert on our phone so we took off
i went back into the canyons took my
kids and my wife
and then we came back about 45 minutes
later
and it looked like the whole rv park was
hit by
the tornado that park filled with people
trying to celebrate spring break
was destroyed as mother nature exits
winter
in a ferocious way jennifer johnson
global news
washington american boxing legend
marvelous marvin hagler has died at the
age of 66.
according to a facebook post by his wife
hegler unexpectedly passed away
in his new hampshire home on saturday
his family hasn't said what caused his
death
hegler was one of the biggest names
during boxing's golden era
from 1976 he went undefeated for over 10
years
and reigned as the undisputed
middleweight champion from 1980
until his final match in 1987 against
sugar ray leonard
in 1983 hagler was inducted into both
the international
and world boxing hall of fame after
retiring he pursued a small career in
acting
and boxing commentary
still ahead as the fight for democracy
continues is myanmar edging close
to revolution
you're watching global national
[Applause]
supporters of aung san tsuchi remain
defiant
returning to the streets of myanmar
today hours after security forces
launched another lethal crackdown
one of the deadliest days since the
military seized power
the acting leader of suchi's democratic
party who remains in hiding
promised a revolution to end the
february coup during his first public
address given from a secret location
he appealed for people to join the
uprising to restore democracy
the pope made another appeal for peace
in syria during his traditional sunday
blessing from saint peter's square
francis offered prayers for the country
on the 10th anniversary
of its civil war it is the 21st
century's deadliest conflict
the pontiff called for a new commitment
from the international community
to end the violence and urged all sides
involved in the fighting to show signs
of good
to give the exhausted population a
glimmer of hope
chile is now one of the top countries in
the world when it comes to its covet 19
vaccination program more than 25 percent
of the population
has received at least one shot the
country of 19 million people
is currently the vaccine champion of
latin america the situation is far
better than at the start of the pandemic
when the chilean government was
criticized for its inability to trace
and isolate
infected people up next a dying woman's
final wish and how she had to say
goodbye to her family
covet 19 has affected just about every
part of our lives
and it can have a profound effect on
death because of pandemic restrictions
a palliative care home in quebec was
forced to wheel a patient
out into the cold the reason so she
could see her loved ones
one last time mike armstrong has the
heart-wrenching moment
her family wants you to see
it was clear what this was a final
goodbye justin boucha the woman on that
bed
had one last wish to see her family
together the kovit 19 rules at the
palliative care center in alma quebec
don't allow more than 10 visitors
bouchard has more than 10
brothers and sisters add to that her two
children
and six grandchildren
my son says having to choose who in the
family could see her and who couldn't
didn't work it wasn't something they
could do
bushah spent two months in hospital she
went in on christmas day
the rules there were even tighter she
was only allowed one visitor her husband
now there was frustration with the rules
the palliative care home but there was
also appreciation it was bouchard who
told her sister-in-law
and best friend to invite our colleagues
at the french network te veau
that kicks are going to should be done
she says soon she won't be around
but asks people to try and make efforts
like this one
to help people since the crisis started
there have been visits through windows
and goodbyes over phones and ipads
whether it was covet 19 or something
else
staffs have tried to be creative but
it's been a challenge
burshall's family says there should have
been a way to hold this visit
inside the home's director says they
would like to operate the way they did
pre-coven but that they have to worry
about other patients as well they do
what they can well as she was being
wheeled back inside
buchal told her best friend it was the
last time she'd see her family
she was right justin boucha died
just hours after this visit mike
armstrong global news
tough tourist story to tell and that is
global national for this sunday night
i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this stunning
sunrise in campbell river bc
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching
donna friesen will be back at the anchor
desk tomorrow and i'll see you wednesday
good night
[Music]
you